[Applause]
[Music]
wow
tommy no tommy did you do that tommy
tommy oh
come on everybody this is no reason to
lose your head
welcome back to the new rock stars and
the breakdown of the boys season two
episode seven
butcher baker candlestick maker i'm
tommy bechtold
and this is the boys underground boys
only except for 33
of us are women yeah
the after show that stays socially
distant so that we're out of the head
pop splash zone
with me to share his thoughts on vaught
is the brain just a little too
many to pop is eric voss hello eric
hi thank you for having me back uh if
this week couldn't get
insane enough uh 2020 just keeps on
going
yes and of course our kill count expert
who had her work really cut out for her
this week marina mastros hello marina
hello i'm back hey we're all back the
three amigos look at us the boys and
girls are back in town
the three i call us the three uh
like the seven but we're where the three
given that uh we all have
we all have dark secrets uh okay so
let's begin this episode
on a personal note uh a loner named
tommy gets radicalized
and you gotta see for me watching an
episode of television where a
overweight man named tommy is
radicalized by the news really hit home
not only could i relate to that
character because he's very good to his
mama
as am i but also he uh frequently buys
snacks
and uh has a lot of screen time
throughout the day so basically
what i'm saying is whoever was my
manager at the time this episode was
filmed
is fired for not getting me and i was
gonna say
you should have been cast where were you
again all right you're out anyway
so our episode summary going back to
business
a loner named tommy gets radicalized by
stormfront's
xenophobic memes and shoots a store
clerk thinking he's a super terrorist
that whole opening sequence was intense
and upsetting
and all kidding aside it was like so
tonally like i mean obviously like not
relatable but like realistic
not not in the shooting part but the
radicalization through memes and stuff
like that
oh it just made me it happens that is
what happens yeah
uh on a weird positive note about that
scene um
my friend like he's like an acquaintance
and improv in canada he's like an actor
it's the guys chris siddiki i think is
his name and he's uh
the cl the clerk the guy so even though
it's like
such a scene i was like yeah yeah
yes yes get that money yes
uh it's always weird when you have
friends who get killed on a tv show
because you're like awesome
yes absolutely well good on you very
we're very sad very soon
sad but uh you know at the end of the
day it's a fictional television show so
no one in that actual scene committed
murder or was
really murdered in real life i know we
all know that
anyway mallory and the uh and the others
plan to use they
they're still executing their plan to
use lamplighter and jonah vogelbaum to
testify against vaught
at congressman newman's hearing but
starlight is captured by black noir so
huey and lamplader have to team up to
break her free
real dream team of uh white superhero
hunks
uh okay no time for porn no yeah yeah
after watching on a time an incredible
amount of time for porn i would say they
work through multiple titles
i don't think i've ever watched a
20-minute porn clip to its entirety
uh these guys watched full dvds yeah
all right anyway that's just a little
bit about my viewing habits butcher
reconnects with his mom
and dad very nice heartwarming scene
between butcher and his dad
butcher blames his brother lenny's
suicide on their dad's toughness which
uh
that whole scene was also kind of hard
to watch because we're getting a little
uh gaze into the dysfunction of uh
william butcher
homelander yeah uh brings his girlfriend
to meet his son
which as as i've said before as a child
of divorce
always an uncomfortable thing uh when
you meet your dad's new
uh lady friend they watch ryan's
charming
lego reenactments of the blind side he
says he did terms
i mean that part you really want to see
dances with wolves so badly
that part to me was so funny because
like the like other than the blind side
the movies that he was referencing are
30 and
40 years old so these are not
recent titles yeah yeah like this kid is
this kid is nine
watching movie yeah anyway homelander
and and stormfront seemed genuinely
embarrassed by
this kid's hobby like they're like this
is some nerd
[ __ ] anyway the two of them uh
plot to replace becca as ryan's parents
then they reveal to ryan that he's
living on the compound
and that his whole life is basically a
lie they then take ryan away
leaving his mother becca in tears
opening the door for butcher to slide
back
in uh lamplighter uh uses
uh his knowledge of vaught tower to uh
trick huey into thinking they're going
to rescue starlight but as soon as they
get there it's revealed that he just led
him
to the statue shrine of the seven uh so
that he could self-immolate
uh burn himself alive but maeve is able
to help starlight
and her mom and huey escape and black
noir
we learn has a tree nut allergy in a
very uh humorous scene god i thought we
i
really thought we were gonna get the
reveal of who black noir is i mean
i kind of feel like what there's one
episode left yeah one left
there's one episode left and i don't
feel like we have sufficient setup for
the mystery of who black noir is going
to be and now i feel like it's going to
be a season three reveal
anyway at the congressional hearing
heads explode like rainer
back in episode one uh vocal bomb dies a
trains replacement shockwave dies
a ton of other people die and get
sprayed with blood as homelanders storm
front look around
uh apparently confused it does appear
that they are genuinely confused by this
so what do you guys think
uh what a crazy ending due to the
episode though tommy and i were talking
beforehand like when as soon as they
showed
raynor's head explosion in the pre-roll
previously on we knew
we knew this whole episode someone said
was going to pop and that made us so
anxious the whole time
there were so many jump scares this
episode the gut-wrenching horror of this
show
knows no bounds i thought it was
hilarious i know it's supposed to be
gut-wrenching and stuff but i was like
oh goddamn yeah
yeah yeah the the correct response is
somewhere between marina and me
[Laughter]
i i was watching it like a little uh
scared boy who
every time there was even a remotely a
moment of suspense i was like that's
gonna explode and i was hiding my head
and i was pausing and rewinding
it was an embarrassing spectacle wearing
a helmet the whole time watching yes
absolutely if i wear a helmet my brain
can't pop that's right i put i put tin
foil
all over my head but accidentally in
front of my face too so i couldn't see
it or breathe
yeah between this and uh batman v
superman it's like
you can't have a congressional hearing
without something horrible happening no
abs
absolutely not absolutely not we do have
five theories for who was pulling the
strings of the head pinatas but
i'm gonna break down the top 10 major
easter eggs visual details that you
might have missed from this episode
starting with the episode title butcher
baker candlestick maker
uh is a title from the comic story line
in which butcher attends his dad's
funeral
and it's kind of working out his uh
daddy issues with his dad's body
uh as you know he kind of works through
those issues in the subplot of this
episode in the comics
he pees on his dad's corpse which is
something that butchers suggest doing in
this episode
he ain't got much longer a couple of
months tell me when it happens
i'll piss on his coffin now the deeper
history of the episode title is of
course the whole nursery rhyme
rub-a-dub dub three men in a tub and who
do you think they'll be the butcher the
baker the candlestick maker
all of them out to sea which originated
i looked this up
in the 14th century when the term
rub-a-dub dub
was the most hilarious way of saying
tisk tis
naughty behavior
a tub was a word at the time for a peep
show
so the idea that is it doesn't matter if
you're a butcher or a baker or
candlestick maker
all men in society have the same dirty
desires
[Music]
and i think the fun part of this episode
is how big of a role porn plays in it
and porn parodies it is kind of like the
recurring motif of the episode
lamplighter's got a whole bag filled
with these porn dvds
and if you think about it the whole
commentary is this idea of climax driven
media
desensitizing us like all these
characters are kind of desensitized and
fittingly
the finale of the episode the boys are
watching on screen
cozying up together on a couch with
popcorn this head popping climax
uh and it's like the whole episode it's
kind of this gross peep show that we all
rub a dub dub dude
i do not i do not false
all right the next detail let's talk
about this whole prologue sequence
it was amazing this character tommy
peterson is played by charlie koontz who
played fat neil on community uh and in
that episode it's the advanced dungeons
and dragons
neil plays a struggling nerd that the
study group tries to help out with the
dnd campaign
and it's revealed that jeff winger was
the one who invented the nickname fat
neil
similarly here tommy's heroes let him
down
he has posters all over his walls for um
and merch for stormfront
uh it's her social media campaign that
gradually wears him down
radicalizes him he's got a black noir
poster that's the same comic book cover
that huey passed back in episode one of
the season
and it gets so brainwashed that he
actually if you look closely there's a
shot where you can see the clerk's eyes
flash a pale blue yeah and we're seeing
it from his perspective
uh just to give you a sense of how
messed up his his head is now uh the
third
detail one of the memes on tommy's feed
shows congresswoman newman with a target
over her face
very much evoking the tea party image
with the target over gabby giffords
district
that went around right before she was
shot newman also foreshadows herself as
a target by referencing
omar's line from the wire if we're gonna
take a shot at the king
we can't miss you come at the king you
best not miss
yeah of course all this setting up that
whole head-popping attack at her hearing
though it looks like she gets away
malory is able to get her out of there
but her assistant lisa is
dunzo gone another one of tommy's
posters shows soldier boy
that's the captain america style world
war ii era soup
back from the 40s there's a statue of
soldier boy invot park
it's a bit similar to the real life
statue of captain america that's in
brooklyn
stan edgar referenced soldier boy back
in episode one of the season
and soldier boy we have learned has been
cast with jensen ackles playing him
uh so we will be seeing that character
in season three very excited
yes um so in this episode uh billy
butcher's father is played by john noble
who you might know as denithor
and it's just so great to see these two
alongside each other carl urban of
course played eomer in lord of the rings
and guys i'm you know i might have been
reading too much in this by seeing this
lord of the rings connection but there
was a moment where mallory tells mm
go and never come back which for me uh
reminded me of gollum
i love her
[Music]
because mallory is kind of gone yes
oh my god you sick
um so we did get some confirmation about
lamplighter's scandal last episode i
theorized that lamplighter banged not
just
underage girls but high school
cheerleaders
which is why he got so uneasy when they
said he looked like a baton twirling
majorette in this episode he admits to
huey
me and mr marathon used to sneak college
girls in this way
college girls really they're replying oh
and by the way mr marathon is a
speedster
soup that a train replaced he was
referenced by ashley recently
you served four years longer than mr
marathon now that is something okay
and newman confirmed lamplighter
actually did sleep with high school
cheerleaders
scrundled ex-soup i'm fairly sure he's
half the sacred heart cheerleading squad
okay stormfront asks ryan if he's into
normal kids
stuff you know besides blindside lego
reenactments uh
but she mentions pewdiepie so are you
into any things that you know kids are
into
yeah like uh nba 2k
pewdiepie it's just a little example of
how plugged in stormfront is but also
it's probably likely that pewdiepie
showed up on stormfront's radar when
that whole white supremacist shooter in
new zealand said subscribe to pewdiepie
during the live stream
right probably uh and there's that
little moment where homelander
lists his movies uh let's see there's
homelander origins
uh homeland arrives of a hero i'm
blender darkest day homeland brightest
night
oh your dad is so good in homeland or
brightest night
darkest day brightest night it's kind of
a nod to the green lantern oath but also
the way stormfront
loves him in brightest night as in
brightest
k in ight like the whitest warrior who's
gonna lead this race war
along with this new aryan little boy
that they're taking back with them yes
yeah
everything she says she can't say
anything that's not racist
yeah okay so uh black noir yes has a
tree nut allergy uh he was foiled with
knaves stuffing and an almond joy to his
mouth actually calls back episode four
if you remember
when he made the tech annika throw away
her
almond joy
yeah now uh nathan mitchell is the actor
who plays
black noir under the mask we weren't
sure if that was gonna be a misdirect
and they're gonna have a different face
there uh but that actor has a nut
allergy himself which is reportedly
where this uh tweets came from
oh my god i'm sorry i was gonna say cute
but is it cute
it's cute it's very deadly but cute
the mask is lifted up we do briefly see
the bottom half of his face
and i gotta say that does very much look
like nathan mitchell's face
um some are saying it looked burned but
now it's interesting i i gotta admit i
did get very excited when blackmore
smashed starlight on the v
table because it did break into an l
shape maybe for lenny but no no
unfortunately no it looks like now um
now you know i'm thinking black mark
could actually be
m's brother because black noir has a nut
allergy
mm has ocd there could be and there was
that moment where black noir was
sobbing when he found out that he had a
compound
like they maybe there's some kind of
connection with his uh dad's death and
it's all kind of linked back because
there is going to be some twists with
black noir where i'm still waiting to
see which twist is going to be
okay eagle the archer becomes the latest
outcast of the church of the collective
kind of the way scientology has labeled
x members like leah remini as
sps suppressive persons um and they leak
all this bad press about them like if
you were to try to google
uh leah remini the first thing to show
up is uh like leah remedies a liar.com
scientology buys all the google adwords
yeah it's messed up um now if you look
closely at the chiron on the tv special
about it it says
eagle is currently the number one search
on soup porn.com
nice i love it uh just another example
of this whole porn motif
porn dan um now we have arrived to the
head popping congressional hearing
uh but to me the most interesting thing
about this other than you know people's
heads randomly exploding
stormfront and homelanders reactions
i've watched this so many times trying
to
frame by frame look at their micro
expressions i gotta say they do look
legitimately stunned and confused by
what's happening
they aren't scared maybe because they've
been desensitized to like
exploding carnage around them but they
are kind of like being used like
hmm this is odd
to me i don't know it suggests that they
aren't behind this or
they are at least very good at acting
surprised
right yeah he the homelander seemed like
genuinely surprised and also not afraid
for himself which
which made me think that they just
assumed that they're immune
to that even though technically they
could not
be like this could be the one way to
kill them both but neither of them seem
nervous about it at all not at all um
there is that shot where blood sprays on
the portrait of george washington
our first president suggesting to me
this could be a little clue that this
head popping might all be
part of a coup like you blame this on
super terrorists
and you use the same means to
assassinate the president the chain of
command the same way and then set up
homelander to take control the
government in a coup when everyone's
freaking out
um the opening scene of the season was
stan edgar negotiating with the
secretary of defense who is technically
the sixth in the line of presidential
succession uh and i feel like that
was all setting up this this whole thing
the opening of this episode was this guy
tommy uh freaking out that soup
terrorists are a huge threat so if that
plus
you know a soup terrorist attack in a
congressional hearing i feel like that
could be grounds of a
of a coup of them yeah for sure
um so this sets up our our question
before before we move on with the rest
of the episode we got to talk about
who did this i have five theories i want
to run past you guys
all right so let's start with cindy this
is one we've talked about before this is
a telekinetic soup from last episode who
does
burst bods but i don't know about you
guys to me her attacks look more
implosion based as opposed to head
explosion-based she goes like this
yeah and she does it to the whole body
yeah i also gotta say there's some
timeline stuff with her she was
locked up when rainer died and now she's
on the loose
i don't think she would have a reason to
do this but i do believe that she might
get blamed for this
ah yeah i kind of took it as like
in that episode in the when rainer like
the reason i would think it was her is
ra like stormfront borrowed her from uh
sage grove or whatever it's called and
then took her to kill rainer
and then put her back maybe that's
possible yeah
it is possible i mean i don't know it's
certainly a lead i'm sure they want us
to
think it's her so yeah the the second
suspect is a guy i'm calling beardy so
there is an extra
in the background of this hearing room
he has a distinct beard
who looks like he's kind of looking at
several of the victims right as their
heads
explode wow which i might be reading
into it i did kind of feel like this is
a true crime show and i'm looking
at the the town hall meeting for the
golden state killer and be like
him the guy in the background looks
suspect maybe reach
uh let's talk about alistar donna the
church of the collective head so
things do kind of work in favor for the
church right shockwave
specifically was killed and then
alastair did say he wanted to get a
train back on the seven
so that kind of clears the path a little
bit there's a moment where when the deep
was watching on tv
he checked his head like he's worried it
could happen to him
um uh there was also if you remember
stormfront did mention that she used to
be a member of the church
there's all kinds of reasons why it
could help them there's also some
reasons why why would they want to bring
down
vat uh you think they'd want to uh get
involved with that but maybe that's why
they killed vogelbaum because vogelbaum
was about to
you know bring down the company ah it's
it's a likely possibility
maybe the fresco's involved maybe the
fresca has something in it that protects
you from specific uh sonic frequencies
that can blow up your brain
i don't know maybe that is just a random
thing yeah
we should all be drinking fresca yes um
to me the most logical option
is stan edgar so this guy's been very
quiet
and if you think about it rainer did die
the moment she mentioned
uh what she believed to be stan edgar's
plan for a coup
i'm thinking what's happening is what i
was mentioning earlier i think he could
be
through some means maybe himself maybe
through some kind of technology or
another suit he's controlling
uh popping uh people's heads uh state
authorities
raynor congress people people can bring
down vat
in order to protect vat but also use
this as grounds to set up homelander
to take over the white house i wonder if
the fact that they're all so afraid of
him makes me think that either he is
super
or or he has some sort of technology
that makes him super you know like
yeah i don't really have as much of the
how for stan edgar but i do have more of
the why
you know like he definitely has the most
to gain sure
um now um i'm gonna give you one last
wild card option here
ashley barrett poor ashley losing her
hair this season
there was this she seemed the most
freaked out in that room she screamed at
homeland
do something what the [ __ ] you're
supposed to be superheroes yeah that was
so funny very interesting and then there
was that weird moment earlier when maeve
told her for once in your life
be a human being and then she kind of
took to heart
i don't know the next time we saw in the
episode
to be honest i don't have a how or a why
though i just think she was interesting
to watch this episode
yeah yeah totally for sure so we'll see
let us know down below who you think was
behind this
uh and what you think of the theories we
presented we're going to continue
talking about some of the deeper
questions we had this episode before we
ended the finale but first
we've got plenty more to talk about but
first i want to talk about sleep i want
to talk about
slumber i want to talk about laying your
sweet head down on a comfortable pillow
but what comes next your shoulders your
back
your calves and your feet all need to
lay on something and that's where helix
sleep comes in
there are more reasons than ever why you
might not be getting good sleep right
now god knows
the jets lost to the broncos last night
facing a third string quarterback only
an idiot would have bet on the jets
and i am that idiot and i didn't sleep
well but your mattress should not be a
reason why
you're losing sleep helix sleep makes
personalized mattresses
made in america ships straight to your
door with free
no contact delivery free returns and 100
nights
worth of a sleep trial imagine that a
personalized mattress so comfortable
it's like
when you lay down in it someone hugs you
and says there you go
tommy just one in this bed tonight same
as the last four years
that makes sense all right and a hundred
nights if you don't know if your
mattress is working for you after 100
nights
you just don't sleep that's my opinion
you're not a good sleeper it's not the
mattress's fault it becomes a you
problem at that point
so yeah to choose a mattress helix has
made a two-minute quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences
to the perfect mattress for you to
choose a mattress helix made a
two-minute quiz
that matches your body type two minutes
worth of quizzes even i could take that
and i failed three grades
and four more after that a total of
seven failed grades
i basically did middle school and high
school twice i was 30 years old when i
graduated and most definitely
the largest boy in my class eric you
sleep on a helix mattress
why don't you talk about how great that
is for you oh i love
my helix mattress i say that um with
complete sincerity it has
um i've had different dreams now because
normally i don't dream that much because
i've had such restless sleep but now
with like helix is like i'm getting
these
deep deep sleep and i'm like learning
things about myself i'm processing my
day i'm seeing the future
i'm adjusting my life as a result of it
like the sleep i'm getting i feel like i
wake up and i'm rip van winkle and i
have time travel
ah yes but do you dream of tommy oh
constantly
tommy and i sleep on the same helix
mattress yes that's right we do
that's actually true i also own a helix
mattress it's
it's one long helix mattress that
expands we
sleep great grandparents in willy wonka
style
i i have to say this mattress is three
feet away from me right now and it's
taking every ounce of self-control i
have
not to dive in and take a slumber now i
know what you're thinking
i always talk about sleeping alone oh
he's always alone he's complaining
no no no my friends this is by design i
don't want anyone else in this
comfortable bed with me
it's that good okay i could have
millions of people in this bed with me
look at me
listen to me there are people lining up
to get in this bed and i say no
no no no no no let's talk more about
helix though they were awarded the
number one best mattress pick
in 2020 by gq magazine wired magazine
and apartment therapy and you know who
else gave them number one tom bechtold
of tom bechdel publications
just go to helixsleep.com underground
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10-year warranty
that's a decade
worth of guarantees and you get to try
it out for a hundred nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
and imagine the look on the guy's face
when you send back your helix mattress
he's going to go
what a fool this person is impossible to
please
that's what he'll think that's what
they're all gonna think they're all
gonna laugh at you
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at
slash helixsleep.com that's helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com underground for
up to 200.
wow what a bargain what a deal what a
night's sleep
what a life eric shall we go into some
deeper questions maureen yeah let's go
into some dude
are you up for some deeper questions my
friends let's talk
deep deep okay question number one
what do we think was going through
butcher's mind in the final shot of the
episode
yeah that was interesting right they're
asking butcher what do we do what do we
do
to me the only option they have left on
the table for them is for the boys
to take compound v and power themselves
up and
fight one-on-one with the seven you know
what is a stupid answer
um you know how you know how uh
butcher threatened to kill that guy's
family yeah yeah
now he's like now i gotta do it i
kept a promise made a promise i gotta
keep it
that's a lot of work uh yeah i i think
um i wonder if he thinks that compound
like getting super powered might be the
only way they
could potentially be safe like in his
mind he's like if we come across whoever
is popping these heads
maybe if we have powers we can prevent
that or we'll have some sort of
i mean i know that uh shockwave's head
was exploded so obviously
supes can be killed by this person but i
don't know
maybe i think you're right he's i think
i think in his head he was like it's
time for the nuclear option which is
maybe he was like
maybe if i grow a giant dick my wife
will take me
yes i i don't even have to leave the
couch just honestly
and who hasn't asked himself that
hypothetical if only
uh question two we and our
if only i could grow a 17-foot dick
then my girlfriend would take me back
weekly noir watch guys what twist would
black noir
do we expect uh next episode we assume
it's going to be revealed next episode
i don't know i feel like we kind of like
the black do our
intrigue of who his secret identity is
has kind of lost steam for me in terms
of like
the mystery of it like i mean he
certainly had memorable appearances this
season
but i would have expected a little more
like i don't know
pers i think yeah maybe yeah some more
clues at this point
whoever it is is going to be a shock you
know which maybe is maybe it's the right
way what do you guys think
guys what if because there's been no
references
to it at all like they really are
leaving us in the dark um
what if he's stan edgar's son
because he would have put somebody
into uh the program right of like
being a superhero and because you have
to wonder like why is he there like why
is he so invested in this
like white supremacist thing and like he
is not white
so maybe he's like okay fine like i'll
be a part of this
to like have control over it
and like have my son be part of it as
like part of a long-term strategy but
that's like an out there theory no i
could see i could definitely see that
like because we know
uh black noir reports directly to stan
edgar i mean they all
he's all their boss but he has like a
side channel with
uh black noir specifically so if they
could be related yeah i could see that
being the case
yeah um but i'm starting to feel like if
it's not mother's milk's brother
you know because that's the one other
lingerie
mystery that they set up earlier in the
season i feel like we're gonna get some
closure on that
in this next episode i if it's not one
of those things
yeah i could see them punching it to
season three next question do we think
ryan will turn
on homelander or stormfront but first i
want to ask this a little mini question
here
was there a moment in this episode in
that scene where you thought ryan was
going to kill becca by accident oh for
sure
i thought he was gonna saw her in half
with like laser eyes or something
yeah really she holds him back yeah she
holds him back and then he looks down at
her hand like
[ __ ] get your hand off me like one of
those was like no no ryan she's a good
character we don't want her to die
she's the best thing in your life yeah
um
i was worried i was worried but i do
think at this point he's more likely to
turn on homeland or storm front i want
to see he's already kind of turned on
homeland or a little bit
right i want to see him power up like
that could be
something that they don't really suspect
to happen and then
will his name be homeboy
i think i think he's he's gonna turn on
stormfront and it's gonna sound exactly
like this
you're not my mom and then he's gonna
yeah push her into a wood shipper
yes oh that would be awesome oddly
enough the only thing that will kill her
yes part of me doesn't want homeland or
stormfront to lose this season like i
kind of want
the darkest reality to come true for
them
yeah like you don't want to lose a good
villain yeah you know
i want to see how bad things can get all
right and finally guys
uh next episode is the season finale
tears
tears of sorrow as as our season comes
to an end
let's take our final bets who lives who
dies uh what's the season cliffhanger
gonna be
what's our predictions now um i think
everyone's gonna make it except for
ashley because she's
too um like we've seen her be
go through so much and like she just
there's no way she crosses the finish
line like yeah there's
she she just can't she's moses she's not
gonna get there
and then also i think maeve is gonna not
make it through the season but i think
that she's gonna
die in a really heroic way like truly
heroic and like
finally heroic right because she's been
portraying herself as a hero but on the
dl like not acting like one so i think
the way that the rest of the seven and
the world finds out that no she is
actually a hero is
dying trying to kill homelander in
stormfront
interesting yeah i could see that too i
mean maeve's arc this season has been
so tragic and i think yeah unfortunately
she's gonna get scapegoated for the
flight 37
stuff yeah um but i do think the in
terms of like how it's gonna leave
season three
uh i would not be surprised if we had
like a house of cards ian final scene in
the oval office resolute desk
bodies everywhere in home owner
there's a storm front on that desk or
something horrible really
yeah um i think for one thing that i
feel like is mo especially with all of
the season three
news that we've gotten is this is
definitely gearing up to be
a empire strikes back season two where
we do not feel good about our heroes
chances right
at the end yeah i think it's gonna be a
real uh depressing cliffhanger i have
i think we could potentially lose one of
the boys
i think there's been a lot of like
tortured souls [ __ ] out of frenchie this
year
uh i think there's you know i i think uh
mallory certainly feels like her days
are numbered i
i think that the not that she's a one of
the boys but you know she's certainly
down with the cause
i think it could be um i think
i think it's i think whatever the
outcome is it's not going to
like season three is going to be uh uh
uh them fighting back but i think
season two is definitely gonna go down
to the soups i think they're gonna
they're gonna claim victory by the end
of it
now my favorite part of the show the
most
heartwarming element of the show the
part that really just sends me off into
my weekend
with a little pep in my step kill counts
marina
is going to catch us up on the kill
counts for this episode and the
season-long standings as a recap heading
into next season's finale marina what do
you got for us
i got you guys covered in blood
all right okay so there were some
big question marks um in the killis this
this week
like is black noir still alive because
you can survive some of those allergy
attacks if you have
you had an epipen maybe he was reaching
for the epipen i think he got there
maybe he had yeah maybe he had another
one in his pocket if he's really smart
um and so is he still around and who is
doing the head popping right
which we talked about so tommy has one
uh the
guy good job tommy thanks guys
who killed the convenience store clerk
which is very sad but
good for my actor friend yeah all right
and the lamp later has one kill for
himself
we're really making a statement there
and then we have uh the mystery killer
right the unknown head popper with
with 14 kills
yup so at the congressional hearing
there was just the sound of popcorn
really going yeah
and you had a tally bark for every one
of those pops yes uh
the visual the ones that we saw on
screen and then also the ones that we
just
heard those were counted as well um and
then also including shockwave
yeah um so for the oh for the season
overall right
so we're going into the finale so let's
get a recap of
the total kill count for the entire
season
all right starlight frenchy and love
sausage each have
one lamp later has two butcher has
two um but in my heart he has three
because he tried to kill that
maybe i'll never forgive him all right
um so kenji
has at least three but we're not we're
not definitive about who actually lived
and died because somewhere hospitalized
so we'll give him at least three um
cindy from sage grove has between three
and four
i want to say four kashi she's so scary
when she goes like this i'm gonna i'm
gonna give my girl credit
um homelander and black noir each have
five
uh chemical has six go girl and
the unknown head popper has 15
and then this is insane this is insane
you guys
storm our white supremacist nazi
girlfriend from 50 years ago or however
long it is
has 67 kills
plus 6 million jews in the holocaust we
gotta add that every time
every time absolutely yeah so she's a
monster she is
terrible and i don't feel bad that she
misses her daughter i hope her daughter
dies a thousand deaths just to make
stormfront sad
wow yeah she's a terrible person
yeah she she she is truly an awful
person no no arguments there
do you okay but i have to toot my own
horn for a second two two two two
because if you guys remember from a
couple episodes i i literally predicted
exactly who she was you guys like who's
liberty and i was like she's the
original nazi like she's
oh yeah i don't know if you guys
remember that but
you remember toot that horn girl
i was told my pantomime of trombones was
wrong because i do this
and this whereas trouble is really just
this yes
i don't know what i don't know what this
is but uh it's not normal
just tickling the top there's a little
he's a little caterpillar on the top
that i'm petting yes
when i say to my own horn i mean flute
oh yes
i mean car horn yeah yeah
well i'm gonna toot my own horns so i'm
gonna head out of here that's our show
so great to chat with you eric and
marina always
my dear friends my worst enemies tune in
every week
for our reactions to the latest boys
episode subscribe to boys undergrounds
on itunes
or wherever you get your podcasts you'll
get the show earlier the video version
and it's a huge
help to us at new rockstars reminder to
join our official discord by becoming a
patron
at patreon.com new rockstars a discord
we'll be fielding questions that we'll
answer on the show you want to be there
to be part of the conversation plus
every now and then i chime in something
inappropriate and as mentioned
a very nice moderator then tells me to
stop and then i leave
uh in shame you can follow me
at tommy bechtold follow eric ea voss
follow marine at marina mastros follow
new rockstars on socials
follow that person that you've been
interested in on their social media
follow a big man home from the grocery
store to see what he eats to get so big
and subscribe here on youtube to get too
much information on all the stuff you
care about
g'day mates
[Music]
you